[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن إحدى القطع الرئيسية في
الجدول هي من الصليب الأحمر الإيطالي
وهو هذا الحذاء هنا ربما يكون لدى الكثير من
الأشخاص أطفال وهذا يتحدث
إليهم، الحذاء نفسه يمثل
النزوح المناخي لذا الأشخاص الذين
كانوا  اضطررنا للتحرك بسبب
أزمة المناخ [الموسيقى] لذا فإن جدول الاستصلاح هو
في الأساس رسالة أمل، إنها
رسالة مفادها أن الطقس القاسي لا
يجب أن يصبح كارثة، لذا فإن ما
فعلناه هنا هو أننا جمعنا قطعًا من
الحطام من  الكوارث المتعلقة بالمناخ
في جميع أنحاء العالم لدينا قطع من
اليمن من حرائق الغابات والجفاف
لدينا قطع من سوريا من أم من
الجفاف وكذلك لدينا قطع من
أوغندا من الفيضانات لذلك هناك قطع
تمثل ما هي النتيجة إذا
لم نستعد ونستعد  تكيف
المجتمعات، الفجوات الموجودة في الجدول
تمثل الدول الجزرية الصغيرة
التي هي لسوء
الحظ الأكثر ضعفًا، المجتمعات الأكثر ضعفًا
في أزمة المناخ
لدينا الآن 191 جمعية للصليب الأحمر والهلال الأحمر
حول العالم، ومن
أين جاءت هذه القطع  من
الأماكن التي يوجد بها الصليب الأحمر والهلال الأحمر،
وبعد وقوع
كارثة مرتبطة بالصليب الأحمر، تمكنوا من
ذلك أثناء الاستجابة، وكانوا قادرين على جمعها ببساطة ثم قمنا بجمع
كل المواد معًا في
ألمانيا، حيث كان الجدول  تم صنعها ومن
ثم أصبحنا قادرين على تجميع كل شيء
معًا، نعم، استخدم الكثير من الأشخاص
كلمة "عميق" عند وصف
الطاولة، ولكن بشكل عام عندما
يقترب الناس من الطاولة، يكون لديهم
شعور بالأمل أيضًا هنا في واحدة
من تلك  من أهم المؤتمرات أه
يمكننا أن نجتمع حول الطاولة ونتخذ
القرارات حتى لا يصبح هذا
مستقبلنا